Oh
I think there is no source of renewable
energy that replaces 141 fossil fuel
fossil fuel is really great stuff it's
you know concentrated in a few places
it's incredibly energy rich dense in
BTUs it's easy to transport it's too bad
that it's wrecking the planet there's no
silver bullet that replaces it maybe
there's enough silver buckshot if we
gather it all up the energies that we
will rely on in the future things like
wind and solar are far more diffuse and
scattered than fossil fuel they're
everywhere but nowhere in overwhelming
abundance and hence the tactic the sort
of thinking about how to gather them
together is going to have to be
different instead of a few centralized
big burners you know going through
mountains of coal we're going to have to
have an energy system that looks more
like the internet with lots and lots of
nodes lots and lots of people bringing
stuff to market and taking stuff away I
have solar panels all over the roof of
my house in Vermont on a sunny day I'm a
utility I'm firing electrons down the
grid you know my neighbor is cooling his
beer with the sunlight that falls on my
shingles okay that's good in all kinds
of ways it lets us put environmentally
benign technologies like solar panels
into pretty easy use it also reduces the
vulnerability of these systems you know
it's not just banks that are too big to
fail in our economy it's the
agricultural system and the energy
system as well it'd be much better to
have an energy system it depends on lots
and lots of solar panels on lots of
people's roofs because I don't know say
some terrorist decides that he wants to
take out my solar panels he could climb
up on my roof with the hammer and
dismantle them and then I have a problem
but it's not a problem that cascades
across the
the transmission grid you know and it's
not spewing deadly solar particles into
the atmosphere either it's a relatively
small problem and in a planet that's
going to have plenty of problems this
century we need to work hard on keeping
them small
well this is a place where government
subsidy makes sense we need to jumpstart
the production of all this stuff the
cost of them is falling pretty rapidly
and it will fall more rapidly as we get
more and more of them in place that
manufacturing cost curve works to our
advantage here it makes a lot more sense
to subsidize solar panels than it does
to subsidize coal and oil which we
continue to do in large quantities
because we've known how to burn coal and
oil for 200 years we've gotten most of
the manufacturing advantage that we're
going to get from any subsidy now is
just pure pay off too politically
connected players so that's certainly
part of it